I appreciate you man uh big up recall
for another supercharge the problem with
our sisters they love negative side of
they love this negative side of the
community rappers players is what they
love if you black if you're a black guy
who not into streets or player these
girls don't want you just like this one
you just picked a scammer
no I'd rather have a scam oh so it's
okay if it's a criminal
but not a criminal on my heart
bless the fine criminal because I'm not
gonna lie that certain crimes that come
with good intention then go for good
reasons and plus assistance you see this
is what I'm talking about dude we make
excuses for criminals in our community
I would definitely that is not a real
story that's a that's a fable breath
like sending sending them
while they're in jail that's kind of
romantic no don't you think yeah oh wow
you're not a real question yeah let me
ask you a real question yeah
uh raise your hand here if you've dated
a criminal in your life
but what's a criminal like what do you
mean what's up
find Google
what type of crime like criminal they
don't matter I've never dated a drug
dealer go for a bit bad thing I'm so
sorry
um
wow what is defined as a criminal
Cornell University has got you yeah
[Music]
www.law.com.edu says criminal is a
popular term used for a person who is
committed a crime or has been illegally
convicted of a crime criminal also means
being connected with a crime it seems
they keep saying crime quite a lot but
then but then you could be a murderer or
you could be put into jail because of
repossession you know what I mean like
there's yeah exactly that's why I asked
like what type of crime kind of let me
quickly say something here this is why
men are always
hold on I was gonna say sign anyway
forget it listen I've I've been in a
long-term relationship with someone
that's gone jail stayed with them
throughout jail came out of jail still
stayed with them whatever whatever
and obviously that ended because
there's certain things that you go
through in life here that make you
realize what you want do you know what I
mean and what I realized with the fast
life yeah it's nice sometimes you know
your your man is making a quick
couple racks over here in a day or that
but for me personally I don't know about
any anyone else I want to build a legacy
like I want to build a dynasty and with
that it takes patience and I think
nowadays we don't have the patience we
all want quick money quick lifestyle
this and then the other because it's So
Glamorous you're not gonna build a
legacy you're not going to build
generational wealth like that and it's
just and I think ultimately what we need
to understand with women we want
security no matter the method we'll be
able to overlook certain things whether
they're right or wrong right but it's
security it's Financial Security it's
protection that's a problem if you if
you're just like I don't mind if it's
right or wrong no I'm that's a huge of
course error of course but I'm saying
just on a general perspective this is
what the women's mentality is like but
look dating criminals is okay right so
listen let me Christine Lagarde is the
head of the European Union Central Bank
and she's a convicted felon right the
Deutsche Bank
JP Morgan they pay I have a friend at
these investment Banks and they take
Define they take the hit because they
can afford it so they're the white
collar so look the other women they're
choosing the white collar criminals
they're choosing the scammers that are
working in ventral Capital firms they're
choosing the scammers that are that led
to the inflation that's rocking the UK
right so it's again these all women like
scammers all women like alpha males all
they right but they choose different
ones why do we choose the criminals that
ain't making bread why are we choosing
the scammers that ain't making bread
because the other criminals they got
money that's it you know what I'm saying
so I I don't get it but well look for me
freaks I'm 21 right so my past had
happened to me a lot throughout my youth
like my experience has happened to me
during a period of time where I was
still growing and learning ultimately
this is of course not an excuse but in
that period of time that's all we knew
those were the environments we were
around those were the type of people we
were around now you know I'm still a
baby but I'm growing up and I'm
understanding a lot of things and it
took me a while I was in that
relationship for almost three years do
you know what I mean did you did you
love the excitement of danger
was it an adrenaline rush being with
being with that guy and not knowing what
was going to happen next even going in
no no no no okay sure yeah no I think
what it was for me is that I didn't
understand at the time so there was no
excitement being it's not it's not about
the excitement what it was for me it was
that the way I understood an alpha male
at the time and the characteristics they
possessed is very different to the way I
understand it now so there was no
excitement there it's not it's not okay
there is a level of excitement it's just
like when women say oh I see it's just
like when women say a nice guy is boring
he's the then the opposite when you're
with a guy who does dangerous stuff
that's exciting that's right the same
way an Angelic woman is kind of boring
you needed to be a lady in the streets
and a freaking the sheets for a reason
because you need to play good balance
you need to have excitement about you
and then you also need to have good
intentions so sometimes if you're
working outside of the law which would
still make your criminal doesn't mean
you've got bad guy you got bad
intentions that's why I said a lot of
criminals have got transferable skills
why do we always make excuses stop
making excuses bro no bruv no bro
you're making excuses oh well no you
know he might be a bad person doing bad
stuff but he could be a good why do it
it's impossible yeah but why yeah but
you don't make excuses for the guy
that's uh five foot seven
you don't make excuses for the guy
that's five foot five and say well he's
short but he might be a nice person no
you're just like he's too short
I would rather be with him than to be
with you at the end of the world come on
bro that is just crap
better criminals though like just choose
a better Criminal yeah you want to
choose the guy that's selling grass
choose the ones
come on bro like bro there's enough guys
out there that are legit that are making
peas you don't have to pick a criminal
but it's a choice because you know it's
dangerous and it's a it's an adrenaline
rush being anything because you don't
know what's gonna happen next
if I happen to fall in love with it
all you women listen this is my thing
yeah I'm sorry yeah you see me yeah I
think I feel I feel like this yeah
because it's kind of immature when you
think about it really and truly like
laughing a joke hahaha but when it gets
real and you have a kid for one of these
dudes and he goes to prison because he
goes to murk someone and you ain't gonna
see him anytime soon and then it's you
and that kid then you're going gonna be
crying one day you're going to be in
your house crying thinking what why did
I do this bro this is stupid and then
you're going to Remember by bouncing up
and I'm not saying you lot but I'm
saying anybody that does that is going
to bounce up and down laughing right now
because there's loads of little girls
out there that are running around with
these kind of ways right now sleeping
with them raw my man shooting up the
club next thing she's having a kid for
him thinking it's still all good bro do
you know how many like bruh every time I
come London I see these couples like
these struggle couples yeah but a boy
you can tell all he does is smoke all
day lips all black that he smoke you
know what I'm talking about bro yeah and
then he's just wearing them dirty
tracksuits you know them tracksuits with
a bubbling bro he's wearing dolls yeah
and then like boom the girl's like them
skinny girls with the little puffer
jacket you know that little with the fur
on it
yeah and she's wearing tracksuit as well
Bob it might be bubbling as well yeah
and then they're pushing that pram and
then the baby is in there and I'm
thinking that kid ain't got no chance
bro yeah it's not funny bro it's real
[ __ ] do you say in bear with my friends
growing up went gel because they
flipping parents were worthless bro so
it's not funny bro I don't care I don't
care bro like like bro like yeah but
it's not funny for you to always put it
on the women those men
for the young girls
agreeable and then you mark their lives
as well because you're traumatized
you know why I can't quit under
first place
if you don't if you don't go with that
guy if you say if if every black woman
let's just bring it to black women yeah
I know that women outside the community
do as well but look we're talking about
why do black men choose interracial
dating yeah if every black woman or
black girl was like or it was a general
consensus in a black community amongst
the females we do not date criminals
guess what the the the percentage of
criminals would drop significantly more
black boys would be going into stem
degrees but no what do we have grown
women laughing and joking and making
excuses why oh he's a criminal he might
be mocking people but he might have a
good reason and he might be a good guy
that's not good enough bruv
my sisters
you can date a criminal just pick the
right ones wow
make him try for those skills to be it
to put it into good use bring your
knowledge into the table because if I
have somebody that's the criminal it's
got amazing because I'll be like baby
you know you can do use this to do this
be be the Rock in your mind
I don't mind I can help
a good guy
a nice guy there's a difference between
a nice and a good guy good guy nice guy
a guy that why don't you why don't you
help one of those guys why do you need
to help a criminal he's already helping
himself
people he's helping people out of their
their money in their bank accounts so
why do you need to help him more I help
a lot of nice guys the only thing is so
right now I don't want a relationship
but so so everything is
so what do you do when you're not one in
a relationship you just date criminals
I'm not dating anyone so why did you
bring that into the equation that I'm
not dating right now what's that gonna
do it no I'm just saying but I still
help people I still help men I'm still
helping the nice guy any any man you're
not helping no criminals either and any
man that comes into my life man or woman
you'll know that one thing that I'm
about is elevating you because me
elevating you elevates me we one-hand
washing the other so I'm always helping
yeah you can help them get the bank
account as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible